hi I'm Erik Bosse and spider-man far
from home was start-to-finish a thin
service a thrill ride and it was a Sun
finish there cuz what an ending and
massive spoiler warning here I am about
to break down the movies post credits
scenes yes I know you may not have had a
chance to see far from home yet
thus this warning feel free to just
pause this video until you're able to
see the movie and then come back so we
could talk about it cool okay final
spoiler warning Goga Mattamy and
spiderman far from home post credits
scenes folks there are two of them and
they are two of the most shocking and
game-changing post-credit teasers after
a Marvel film adver I'm gonna break down
both and explain why the older nerd
sitting behind you were shrieking okay
the first of these scene shows Peter
back in New York with MJ after his
conflict in Europe he drops off MJ says
goodbye then slings up to a lamppost to
watch a news broadcast on the screens
outside Madison Square Garden the anchor
presents a disturbing video that
mysterio recorded moments before his
death and it cuts to a video Quentin
Beck acting all distressed desperate
saying he doesn't think he's gonna
survive
Piderman it's attacking for some reason
he says he had already weaponized some
stark technology he's saying he's gonna
be the new Iron Man no one else then it
cuts to this video that Quinton recorded
with spider-man but heavily edited with
the audio manipulated to make Peter look
like a villain we hear a female voice
ask are you sure you want to convince
the drone attack there will be
significant casualties and then Mysterio
edited a clip of Peters voice so that it
sounds like he responds I don't care
execute execute them all by the way the
words execute them all contextualized
this way is actually a literary allusion
by Quentin Beck to Joseph Conrad's Heart
of Darkness adapted by Francis Ford
Coppola into the film Apocalypse Now
both of which featured insane warlords
famously losing their humanity evidence
by the quotes exterminate the brutes and
exterminate them all so the video
returns to the anchor who begrudgingly
credits a controversial new site called
The Daily Bugle dotnet and then things
get amazing Jay Jonah freaking Jameson
played by JK freakin Simmons himself who
also played the Daily Bugle editor in
the Sam Raimi spider-man trilogy appears
he says there you have it folks
conclusive proof that Spiderman was
responsible for the brutal murder of
Mysterio an interdimensional warrior
gave His life to protect our planet and
who will no doubt go down in history is
the greatest superhero of all time
that's not all folks here's the real
blockbuster
brace yourself you might want to sit
down so yeah instead of the Daily Bugle
being a print tabloid as we've known it
to be it now appears to be a parody of
Alex Jones discredited conspiracy show
Infowars The Daily Bugle logo and sets
are pretty similar and Simmons even
impersonates Jones bombastic tone but
really this is perfectly aligned with
the kind of dodging ethics and dogged
stubbornness that Jameson has always
been known for now you could interpret
this to mean that Tom Holland Peter
Parker exists in the same universe that
Tobey Maguire's Peter Parker did but
really I think the studio just brought
back the same actor to play the role in
separate movie universes because Simmons
take on the character was just so damn
perfect so damn iconic and he's only
gotten more famous since the early 2000
so why not bring the guy back then the
video returns to Quentin Beck who
reveals spider-man's real name is Peter
Parker and Peter watches in horror
gasping what the mr. Kratz and this is
of course a callback to the final line
of spider-man homecoming when they
realize that Peter was spider-man and
reacted the same way so Mysterio
recorded these tapes ahead of time
because he's a master manipulator
perceptions and media narratives so that
he could shift all blame to Peter as the
villain not himself and being outed and
falsely blamed like this could be very
very bad for Peter but it is also worth
noting that this information is coming
from what looks like a very
untrustworthy source in this universe
shield especially with the help of as
we've seen a second a secret network of
alien shapeshifters could very easily
discredit Jameson as fake news which
would if you think about it dr Jameson
even more insane with rage against
spider-man menace in that could set up
Jameson - as he does in the comics set
up villains like Norman Osborn in the
Scorpion to rein in spider-man perhaps
leading to the formation of the sinister
six that Mac Gargan scorpion loyal cameo
in the homecoming post-credits scene
might have been laying the groundwork
for but let's move on to the second post
credits scene which opened similarly to
the infinity war post credits scene with
Nick Fury Maria Hill in a car except
they ain't pure Ian hill they
shape-shift back and to Skrulls
yeah those of you following my scroll
search series and say I've been wasting
my time despite my first episode dealing
with Nick Fury being a scrolling
disguise who's the idiot now well still
me apparently because this isn't as dark
as it seems only for the duration of
this movie have Furion hill been Scrolls
and disguise specifically this girl's
Talos and his wife seen in Captain
Marvel
Furion Hill have apparently requested
them to fill in for them on earth while
they're offworld the wife says the Talos
you gotta tell him Tayloe says it was
fine the little boy handled it how was I
supposed to know the whole thing was
fake it was all very convincing the
performance illusion that costume the
craftsmanship in that but tailless
admits to being fooled by Mysterio but
still he calls it in hey I hope your
mission is going well we gave the
classes to Parker about a week ago like
you said it was all very touching
shortly after that everything kind of
went off the rails we need you to come
back because everyone keeps asking where
the Avengers and I don't know what to
say and then the call cuts to the real
Nick Fury we thanks lounging on a
tropical beach he hangs up on Talos that
clever callback to Peter Parker hanging
up on Taillow slash Fury earlier fury
stands up and stretches we see that this
Beach is actually just a simulated
reality on a vast scroll spaceship here
he claps everyone back to work and heels
out to the Skrulls who got my shoes so
yes these post credits scenes are filled
with more nerdy twists than like a comic
book left in a dryer but this scroll
reveals sets up a few major elements for
Marvel base or first Nick Fury and
perhaps all of shields are part of some
secret mission deep in space with the
scrolls this could be about anything but
it wasn't just staying out a low slash
fury responded about Captain Marvel
earlier catch him don't bully
maybe Carol Danvers has gone missing or
maybe she betrayed the scroll race in
some way or they think she did really
this whole Talos reveal helps clarify a
lot of furious behavior in the film
because he's really off his game it's
pretty inconsistent like yeah it did it
makes sense that Nick Fury would be
fused by Mysterio potatoes I'm kind of a
dummy but also this scene confirms that
Scrolls exist
earth in the present day and that
character says we know them could
actually be Impostors after all all the
time
now scrolls like Talos are friendly but
in the comics many scrolls shapeshifters
are evil impersonating Avengers posing a
huge threat in the Secret Invasion
storyline which we might see in phase 4
which is why folks that my scroll search
must continue I know it's often bonkers
and it's usually wrong but by
entertaining dumb laughable conspiracy
theories we often dig up the clues that
we never would have considered with our
imaginations closed off and yes this
kind of thinking is totally okay with
fictional fan theories but less so with
real news events so just throw it it
distinction I don't like putting
chemicals in the water it's that kind
the friggin frogs game but who else do
you think could be a scroll imposter in
the MCU where do you think Captain
Marvel could be and do you think people
will believe Jay jonah Jameson about
Peter Parker comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at EA vos and subscribe to the
rockstars and breakdowns and theories
about everything and how one day I will
prove that everybody the scroll
[Music]